This brings us to the very
last session of the 2017
Summer School.
And this session will
be a little unusual.
It will not be just me speaking,
but
we will also have
representatives from the winning
teams of the Malmo
Collaborative AI Challenge.
I'm very excited to be able to
hear about their approaches
in the end of the session.
But first of all,
I will give a brief introduction
of the Malmo Platform and
our long term goals,
why we built this platform.
I will introduce the Malmo
Collaborative AI Challenge and
give you a sense of the task
that teams had to address there.
And then I'll switch
over to Sean who will
be introducing the teams and who
will discuss their approaches.
So Project Malmo, you have very
briefly at least heard about
this yesterday during the dinner
when we presented the awards to
this team.
Project Malmo is a platform
that my team and myself have
developed here in the Cambridge
Lab over the past two years.
We open sourced this
platform about a year ago.
So if this is something that
you think is exciting that you
could potentially use for your
research or use to learn about
various AI techniques, for
example, reinforcement learning,
then this is something that
you can download right now.
It comes with a bunch
of examples that,
especially Dave there, has put
a lot of time in developing.
It comes with tutorials, so this
is something ready to try today.
But why did we feel the need for
developing an experimentation
platform for
artificial intelligence?
And why did we select the game
Minecraft as the platform or
as the basis for
that particular platform?
The long term aim
of my research and
a lot of people in
the community is to develop AI
technology that allows us to
address real-world applications.
Now, when we move towards
real-world applications,
there's typically a problem
that it's usually expensive,
difficult, or dangerous to
actually do experiments in those
real-world settings that we're
addressing in the long term.
So there's often this need that
we need to come up with, for
example, a laboratory
environment or
a simulated environment in which
we can test out and refine our
ideas until we have a good
understanding of how they work.
And we can actually translate
them into real-world
applications.
Now you see, computer games,
video games as one
particularly interesting and
important environment for
setting up those kinds
of simulations,.
Because in many important
respects, they are able to
capture some aspects of
real-world interactions,
while also abstracting from some
of those characteristics that
make real-world experiments
expensive, dangerous, or
very difficult.
The reason we selected
Minecraft is that it
particularly incorporates some
of those characteristics that we
are particularly interested
in in the research and
where we also hope to encourage
the research community
to look at those
particular problems.
And they're just three of
those aspects that I want to
mention and emphasize here.
And there are others as well.
The first aspect is,
that in the real world,
we have a wide range,
a wide variety of tasks and
goals that we are trying to
achieve, and that we would like
AI technologies to
be able to address.
But at the same time,
those sets of tasks and
problems are typically not
some loose random collection
of things that we throw at,
for example, people, or
the AI technologies that we
want to be able to solve them.
Instead, those problems
are typically related
according to some rules,
to some you could say,
common sense regularities that
we find in the real world.
For example, typically in
real-world environments,
we have 3D geometry.
We have certain spacial
regularity that is very
important.
And all that information, that
regularity, are things that we
can put as inductive bias into
the solutions that we develop.
And using those effectively,
typically allows us
to speed up learning.
So by developing an
experimentation platform on top
Minecraft, we are able to use
a world in which there is this
rich but also regular structure.
There is a physics in Minecraft
that is not identical to
real-world physics, of course.
But if you have played Minecraft
before, you know that you cannot
put water in thin air,
that's sand falls down,
that when water and lava meet,
they form obsidian, etc., etc.
So there are all these rules,
all those regularities,
that can be exploited, and
third upon, when an agent, or
when an IA Agent, is trying
to learn to solve a new task.
In addition to that,
what we were looking for
was an environment that could
support a wide range of ideas
and approaches.
And this is something where
Minecraft plays a very
interesting role.
For example, in the sense that
it provides a world in which,
for example, there is a natural
way of discretizing or
in some characterizing the world
in many different ways.
And just to give you an example
here, the platform that we have
built does not presuppose
that people use, for example,
reinforcement learning.
You can use planning or
other classic AI approaches.
But just to give you examples
from the reinforcement learning
literature, this is something
that I'm particularly
familiar with.
You can, for example,
construct tasks that are very
similar to classic discrete,
state discrete action-types of
reinforcement learning tasks.
Where, an agent represents
the world, for example, by those
squares, those individual
innumerable states that
it can encounter as it explores
the world and interacts with it.
And at the same time,
we can move to a different
space of observation.
So for example, the agent could
also observe the video image
of the world from a first
person perspective.
So we provide a platform where
there are these different
observation handlers that give
different types of observations
to the agent.
There are different kinds
of command handlers.
And by using those,
we can create problems that
are specifically targeted at
the technology that we
are trying to explore.
And it also allows us to
start combining techniques in
other ways.
And I think moving forward,
combining ideas from, for
example, different communities,
has a lot of potential of
helping us address interesting
problems in the future.
Finally, one area that I
am particularly excited
about is this area of
learning to collaborate and
communicate with other agents.
And in the long term, the kinds
of agents that I would want
our AI agents to communicate
with are people.
So in the long run, we
are aiming to develop technology
that can collaborate with
people, empower them and
assist them in achieving the
goals that they are looking for.
So for those kinds of problems,
creating environments where
tasks are based on
collaboration and
communication are very
important.
The platform that we have
developed comes ready-made for
those kinds of challenges.
So for example, at the top here,
there's this screenshot of
a task where two agents are
collaborating to solve a maze.
In the lower rung,
there's a very specific example
of bringing a natural language
component into a task.
So these are all capabilities
that are all already provided
by the platform.
And the platform is very generic
in the way that it allows you to
create a new task using
a simple XML format.
Putting on some
reward structure or
some other information that
should be provided to the agent
and you're ready and can go
about focusing on experimenting
with the agent rather than
investing an enormous amount of
time in setting up some
kind of new simulation or
some laboratory setting in
which to run the experiments.
Now after this very brief
overview of project Malmo,
I want to switch to the Malmo
Collaborative AI Challenge.
And as we mentioned before, the
Malmo Collaborative AI Challenge
was a challenge that we ran for
the first time this year.
And we set this up with
the goal of fostering research
in especially collaborative AI.
So in developing, modeling, or
training AI agents that can
learn to collaborate
with others.
This challenge was open to
participating teams of graduate
students worldwide.
And I believe Sean will tell you
more about the participants that
we actually had.
It ran in April and
May 2017 of this year.
And we were able to
award two sets of
prizes to the winning teams.
And those decisions
were announced in June,
just about a month ago.
There were two sets of prizes,
one set of prizes
were attendance for
the winning teams of the AI
Summer School, right here.
So it's of great pleasure to
welcome those winning teams here
at the Summer School.
And the second set of prizes was
an Azure for research grant, and
like Shemund mentioned
earlier in his talk.
This is a large amount of
compute resource that we hope
will allow the winning teams to
take their approaches further,
invest more in their research,
and come up with novel,
new ideas and insights.
In the remaining few
slides of my talk,
I want to briefly walk you
through the challenge task and
to motivate in which way this
is particularly challenging and
interesting and how it captures
some of the key challenges that
we need to address in developing
collaborative AI agents.
And luckily for me, Shemund
has already motivated some of
the difficulties in
multi-agent scenarios.
So this goes very much back
to these questions around
games from a game
theoretic perspective.
The task that we
formulated here,
starts from the classic
formulation, the classic
game theoretic formulation that
is known as the Stag Hunt.
And you can see the classic
formulation there.
This type of game was
first described by
Jean-Jacques Rousseau
who captured some ideas,
some kind of challenges
in working out
social dilemmas around deciding
whether to cooperate and
coordinate, or whether to go for
your own rewards or safety.
So the way that this
is typically set up
is that there are several
hunters who go on a stag hunt.
If they want to catch a stag,
they need to collaborate
because it's a very large prey.
If they manage to
collaborate successfully,
they all get a high reward.
So in this example
of two hunters,
let's say there could
be a value of five to
everyone who coordinates
in catching the stag.
Alternatively, each hunter
could try to catch a hare,
which is easier to catch, can
be caught by an individual, but
has a smaller payoff.
If everyone catches a hare,
they each get a reward which is
fairly safe, but it's smaller
than that of coordination.
The conflict arises because
if one agent is trying to
coordinate while the other
is going for the hare,
then the agent that is trying to
coordinate and collaborate will
actually be empty-handed, so
they will get a reward of zero.
And so this creates this
tension of trying to estimate
what the other agent might do.
There are two pure Nash
equilibriums here in
this make sum game.
One is where both coordinate.
One is where both go for
the hare.
And then,
there's also a mixed strategy
that uses various percentages,
various probabilities for
one or the other.
Now, the variant of this team
that we based our task on,
was this extended version of the
stag hunt that was proposed by
Yoshida and colleagues in 2008.
And I particularly
like this form of
the game because it extends it
with some various aspects around
understanding how to
coordinate with another agent.
One aspect that they were
particularly interested in in
studying is what they
call the Theory of Mind.
And this is this idea
that if you want to
compute your optimal strategy,
then you need to know
some information about the other
agent's information state.
So you need to reason about
the other's agent's strategy
in order to conjure with an
effective strategy of your own.
And this creates, again, this
recursive dilemma of reasoning
about what they, what you know,
what they know, etc, etc.
Also, this formulation
introduces and
interesting aspect of signaling,
which you could see as
some kind of language.
So for example, if I'm the green
agent down here at the bottom,
and I move let's say to
the right, then the red
agent could infer that as
a signal that you were trying to
move towards the stag, that you
are trying to be cooperative.
So then you can have this
additional dimension where you
try to interpret the other
agent's actions.
In a way that allows you to gain
additional information about
their strategy.
So it's an interesting
form of communication
that doesn't require
natural language per se.
Now our formulation of the task
was a translation of this game
theoretics stag hunt problem
into the Minecraft world.
You can see here the interface
that we provide for
human players to play the game.
So, you can actually try this,
and try this out again.
This is something where
we provided the task and
the baseline starter
code on GitHub.
So if you would like to play
around with those kinds of
tasks, you can download this and
try it out.
We provide two kinds of
observations to the human
player.
And for the AI agents, teams
are also free to choose one or
the other.
The first one is
a first-person perspective,
which creates this very
difficult problem of having
to deal with partial
observability.
The other one is a more global
observation based on your
top down view of
the current agent.
So here,
I would be the red agent.
I could see the pig and
the blue agent position there.
And then, my goal would be to
pick a strategy that allows
me to either catch the pig
by cornering or pinching it.
Or, I could go for safety,
go to one of the exit squares on
the left or to the right and get
the small reward by abandoning
my potential collaborator.
The task was set up in
a turn taking fashion so
each agent would act
one after the other.
However, the pig was maintained
with normal Minecraft dynamics
so it could suddenly
start to run around.
And there might be strategies,
for example, in waiting in
a strategic position until
the pig might show up there.
I don't want to say much
more about the game and
how it was solved.
We will hear about that,
as I mentioned,
from the winning teams,
in just a few minutes.
One thing that impressed me
personally a lot was to see
the huge variety
of approaches and
strategies that teams tried out
for this particular challenge.
And our conclusion, so far,
was that there was no
obvious winning strategy.
And I think, moving forward,
it will be really interesting to
think about the various
ingredients that make people be
successful in this
particular task.
And to understand how some of
those might be combined into
future, more effective
strategies for
solving collaborative games.
I just want to conclude my
slides with a short outlook.
I think Collaborative AI, so
developing AI technology that
can learn how to collaborate,
especially with humans, has huge
potential for transforming the
way we currently think about how
we interact with machines and
what machines can do for us.
I think this is an immensely
rewarding research area.
And you happen to be in
a position that is perfect for
developing the next generation
of collaborative AI technology.
I'd like to encourage you to
think about those problems.
And if there are any areas that
you're particularly interested
in, for example, in terms
of creating new tasks for
future collaborative
AI challenges,
then come talk to
me after this talk.
Thank you so much.
>> [APPLAUSE]